and I love cheese and I love a good
cheese plate a couple of hard cheeses
you would go with a Manchego a cheddar
perhaps and then you would go with like
a couple of soft cheeses I love a
Camembert I love a Brie I like a blue
which is like a combination of a hard
and soft cheese but like I like the funk
kind of good prosciutto chorizo give me
anything that is like very salty maybe a
little bit spicy perhaps like a little
like spicy jelly on the side every good
cheese plate has a carrier cracker which
is thin flavorful but not too powerful
then you've got a cracker what I like to
call maybe a little bit more substantial
an oat cracker and then lastly I'm a
huge fan of a Sourdough baguette loaf
cut into little pieces
[Music]
oh